MEMBER THE SENATE WILL COME TO
ORDER THE SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN ALVARADO. GIL
ARCHULETA, ASHBY, ATKINS BECKER,
BLAKESPEAR, BRADFORD CABALLERO,
CORTEZ DALI. ODD DURAZO, EGM
GLASER, GONZALEZ GROVE, HURTADO
JONES, LAIRD LIMÓN MCGUIRE
MANJAR MIN. NEW MIN. WHEN NELO
ORB A PORTANTINO ROTH RUBIO,
SEYARTO SKINNER, SMALL CUEVAS
STERN HUMBERG WAHAB WIENER WILK.
MEMBERS OF QUORUM, HIS PRESENCE
HAVE MEMBERS. PLEASE RETURN TO
THEIR DESK, PLEASE. MM. MEMBERS
OF QUORUM IS PRESENT. I WOULD
LIKE TO INVITE MEMBERS AND OUR
GUESTS BEYOND THE RAIL AND IN
THE GALLERY. PLEASE RISE. WE
WILL BE LED IN PRAYER THIS
AFTERNOON BY SENATOR NILO AFTER
WHICH PLEASE REMAIN STANDING FOR
THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE,
SENATOR NILO OUR PRAYER TODAY IS
FROM PSALM 20. MAY THE ONE WHO
CREATED YOU IN WHOLENESS. MEET
YOUR NEEDS WHEN YOU CALL MAY THE
NAME OF LOVE, BE YOUR PROTECTION
AND RISE UP IN YOUR HEART AS A
TOWER OF STRENGTH. MAY ALL YOU
HAVE GIVEN IN GRATITUDE AND WITH
OPEN HANDS BE RETURNED TO YOU,
100 FOLD. MAY YOUR HEART'S
DESIRES AND ALL YOU PLANNED BE
FULFILLED IN DUE SEASON. LET US
SHOUT FOR JOY. AS LOVE TRIUMPHS
OVER FEAR. LET OUR THANKFUL
HEARTS SING ALOUD ACCLAMATION TO
THE BELOVED WHO ANSWERS OUR
PRAYER FELT OUR HEARTFELT
PRAYERS. OH, BELOVED, YOU HAVE
CREATED US HERE OUR CALL AND
MAKE YOUR HOME IN OUR HEARTS.
AMEN. MEMBERS. PLEASE JOIN ME IN
THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE
FLAG. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE
FLAG. AMERICA.
MEMBERS. MEMBERS WE ARE
PRIVILEGED TO HAVE WITH US HERE
IN OUR GALLERY TODAY, MR OSUMI
YO, GENERAL COUNSEL. OF JAPAN,
BASED IN SAN FRANCISCO. WE
WELCOME YOU TO THE SENATE.
CALIFORNIA HAS ENJOYED A VERY
LONG STANDING RELATIONSHIP WITH
THE COUNTRY OF JAPAN. MANY OF
OUR CITIES HAVE SISTER CITY
RELATIONSHIPS WITH CITIES IN
JAPAN, AND WE WELCOME YOU.
GRACIOUS ARMS HERE. THANK YOU
FOR BEING WITH US. SENATOR ALLEN
FOR PURPOSES OF INTRODUCTION.
SENATOR ALLEN. YES. THANK YOU,
UM THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT. UM
I. I RISE THIS AFTERNOON WITH
THE GREAT HONOR OF RECOGNIZING
THE DEDICATION AND SUCCESS. OF
CALIFORNIA'S BEST AND BRIGHTEST
YOUNG PEOPLE, PARTICULARLY IN
THE ARTS. UH, AS MANY OF YOU
KNOW, THIS MORNING MARK THE
CULMINATION OF THE 19TH ANNUAL
POETRY OUT LOUD STATE
COMPETITION, WHICH WAS HOSTED BY
CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL AND
CALIFORNIA POET LAUREATE LEE
HERRICK. IN FACT, IT WAS IT TOOK
PLACE RIGHT OVER IN THE SWING
SPACE, SO WE, WE HOSTED IT AS A
LEGISLATURE. UH, SINCE 2005 THE
CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL HAS
PARTNERED WITH THE NATIONAL
ENDOWMENT FOR THE ARTS AND THE
POETRY FOUNDATION TO GIVE
STUDENTS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DISCOVER THEIR VOICES. AND ADD
THEM TO THE GENERATIONAL
CONVERSATION OR OF ART AND
CULTURE. AND OVER THE LAST TWO
DAYS, WE'VE HAD COUNTY CHAMPIONS
FROM ALL OVER THE STATE FROM
HIGH SCHOOLS, AND THEY CAME HERE
TO SACRAMENTO TO COMPETE IN
PERFORMANCES OF POETIC WORKS
THAT THEY MEMORIZED AND MADE
THEIR OWN. NOW LET ME FIRST
WELCOME ALL OF THE COUNTY
CHAMPIONS TO SACRAMENTO. THE
HARD WORK AND COMMITMENT
REQUIRED TO MAKE IT THIS FAR WAS
NÓ SMALL ACHIEVEMENT. AS
STUDENTS WHO CHOOSE TO ENGAGE
WITH THE ARTS ON THIS LEVEL,
STUDYING THE INTENTION OF OUR
LITERARY HISTORY AND INVESTING
IN THE SKILLS NECESSARY TO
EXPRESS IT PERSONALLY, THESE
COMPETITORS REPRESENT THE NEXT
GENERATION OF CULTURAL AND
COMMUNITY LEADERS IN OUR STATE.
SO JUST A FEW HOURS AGO IN THE
SWING SPACE. THOSE STUDENT
LEADERS, UH, DELIVERED THEIR
RECITATIONS IN A BID TO EARN THE
CHANCE TO REPRESENT OUR STATE,
UH, AT THE NATIONAL COMPETITION
IN WASHINGTON, Dð èC AT THE END
OF APRIL AND AFTER A LONG
WEEKEND OF COMPETITION UH UH,
OUR CHAMPIONS, UNFORTUNATELY HAD
TO BEGIN THEIR TRAVEL HOME AND
THEY CAN'T BE WITH US ON THE
FLOOR TODAY, PARTLY BECAUSE OF
THE CHANGING SCHEDULE WITH THE
SECRET WITH THE STATE OF THE
STATE, BUT, UH BUT I DID WANT TO
MAKE A MO UH, MAKE A POINT OF
RECOGNIZING THEIR ACHIEVEMENT,
UH, HERE NONETHELESS. SO IT'S MY
HONOR TO ANNOUNCE OUR TOP THREE
COMPETITORS IN THIS YEAR'S
POETRY OUT LOUD STATE FINALS,
EACH OF WHOM PERFORMED THREE
WORKS OVER THE LAST FEW DAYS.
UH, THIS YEAR'S HONORABLE
MENTION WENT TO SHEILA JOHNSON
L, A COUNTY'S CHAMPION. THE
RUNNER UP FROM RIVERSIDE COUNTY
WAS MIRABEL LEE. AND FROM SONOMA
COUNTY. THE CHAMPION RILEY
O'HARA, RIGHT AFTER SAINT
PATRICK'S DAY, THE NEWLY MINTED
2024 POETRY OUT LOUD STATE
CHAMPION. SHE WILL BE, UH UH,
RILEY WILL BE COMPETING ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA AT THE
NATIONAL FINALS. SO THIS IS
OBVIOUSLY A PERSONAL VICTORY FOR
EACH OF THEM AND ALL THE
COMPETITORS, UH, BUT IT'S THEIR
COURAGE AND THEIR ARTISTIC
EXPRESSION THAT REALLY HELPS TO
CONTRIBUTE TO THE RICH TRADITION
OF THE ARTS. HERE IN CALIFORNIA
MEMBERS PLEASE REC. PLEASE JOIN
ME IN RECOGNIZING THE INCREDIBLE
WORK OF THESE DEDICATED STUDENTS
FROM ALL AROUND OUR STATE. THANK
YOU, SENATOR ALLEN AND
CONGRATULATIONS TO THOSE
FINALISTS. MEMBERS OF BASEBALL
SEASON IS JUST AROUND THE
CORNER. AND WE HAVE AN
EQUIVALENT RIGHT HERE ON THE
SENATE FLOOR. WE HAVE A TRIPLE
HEADER. RIGHT HERE IN THE SENATE
. LET ME NOTE THAT, UH, TODAY IS
THE BIRTHDAYS OF SENATORS WILK,
ALLEN AND GROVE. PLEASE JOIN ME
IN WISHING THEM A HAPPY
BIRTHDAY. I DON'T KNOW IF
THERE'S A TRIPLE HEADER IN
BASEBALL, BUT I WAS TRYING THAT
OUT. ALL RIGHT. MESSAGES FROM
THE GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED
READ. MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY
WITH THE SECRETARY. PLEASE READ.
MISTER PRESIDENT. I AM DIRECTED
TO INFORM YOUR HONORABLE BODY
THAT THE ASSEMBLY ON THIS DAY
PASSED ASSEMBLY BILL 1887 SUE
PARKER, CHIEF CLERK OF THE
ASSEMBLY. THANK YOU. REPORTS OF
COMMITTEE WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. MOVE
NEXT TO MOTIONS, RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES. WITHOUT OBJECTION. THE
SENATE JOURNALS FOR MARCH 11TH
2024 THROUGH MARCH, 14TH 2024
WILL BE APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY
THE MINUTE CLERK. MEMBERS
WITHOUT OBJECTION. JOINT RULE
62, A WILL BE WAIVED FOR THE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE AND THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE TO HEAR
A B 1887 WITHOUT THE FOUR AND
TWO DAY NOTICE IN THE DAILY
FILE. MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION.
ASSEMBLY BILL 1887 WILL BE GIVEN
A SECOND READING UPON BEING
REPORTED FROM THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE ON WEDNESDAY. MARCH
20TH 2024 AND FINALLY, MEMBERS
WITHOUT OBJECTION. THE FOLLOWING
BILL WILL BE WITH FLOOR
AMENDMENTS WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. THAT'S P
FILE ITEM. 10 S¼ èC R 119 BY
SENATOR UMBERG. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE NEXT TO CONSIDERATION OF
THE DAILY FILE. FIRST UP AS
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENT ITEM
NUMBER ONE, SENATOR GROVE IS
PREPARED. THANK YOU, MISTER
PRESIDENT BEFORE I START
COLLEAGUES, DID YOU DROP THIS ON
THE WAY IN? NOW THAT I HAVE ALL
YOUR ATTENTION. I LEARNED THAT
ON SOUTHWEST FLIGHT THIS MORNING
, IT WAS ACTUALLY PRETTY
ENTERTAINING. WE LAUGHED AND
CLAPPED I ITEM ONE IS A
CONFIRMATION OF JOSEPH ITO FOR
APPOINTMENT TO THE CALIFORNIA
INDEPENDENT SYSTEMS OPERATOR
GOVERNING BOARD. MR ITO HAS BEEN
A STAFF SCIENTIST AT THE
LAWRENCE BERKELEY NATIONAL
LABORATORY SINCE 1982 SKY'S
WICKED SMART, UM, HE DESERVES TO
OPERATE ALL THOSE LITTLE
COMPUTERS THAT KEEP THE POWER ON
IF WE CAN SUPPLY IT TO HIM. HE'S
ALSO A MEMBER OF THE INSTITUTE
OF ELECTRICAL AND ELECTRONICS
ENGINEERS, AND HE WAS APPROVED
BY THE RULES COMMITTEE ON MAR.
SIX ON A 50 VOTE. RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR GROVE. ANY DISCUSSION ON
THIS NOMINEE? ANY DISCUSSION?
NONE. SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL, ADAM. HØI ALVARADO, GAIL
HØI ARCHULETA HØI ASHBY, I,
ATKINS ALL BECKER ALL
BLAKESPEAR. BRADFORD. HØI
CABALLERO. HØI CORTEZ. UH, DALI.
HØI DAD. AYE, TOO. HØI EGM ALL
GLAZER IY ALL GONZALEZ ALRIGHT,
GROVE. ALL RIGHT, JONES. AYE,
LAIRD. AYE, LIMÓN. MCGUIRE,
BILLY MON, I MAGUIRE IY MANJAR.
AYE MIN. UH, NEWMAN. AYE. WHEN
HØI NILO. AYE, Ó. HIYA. AYE,
PORTANTINO. AYE, ROTH. AYE,
RUBIO. I SEE YOU TO, UH SKINNER.
SMALLER CUEVAS. AYE, STERN. HØI
HUMBERG ALL WE HAVE AYE, WIENER.
AYE, WILK. HØI HIS COLL ABSENT
MEMBERS. SHAKESPEARE. AYE.
SKINNER. HØI ON A VOTE OF 40 TO
0. THE NOMINEE IS CONFIRMED.
MEMBERS. WE'RE NEXT GOING TO
MOVE TO SENATE THIRD READING AND
FOLLOWING THAT ASSEMBLY. THIRD
READING. THIS IS A TOTAL OF SIX
MEASURES THAT WE'RE GONNA HEAR
THIS AFTERNOON. IF YOU WANT TO
FOLLOW ALONG ON YOUR SCORECARD,
THESE ARE A FILE AND ITEM 78.
1213 AND 14 AND NUMBER 21. SO
WE'LL BEGIN FIRST WITH FILE ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN. THIS IS S¼ èC R
116 BY SENATOR JONES, SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ SENATE AND CURRENT
RESOLUTION 116 BY SENATOR JONES
RELATIVE TO FRONTAL TEMPORAL
DEGENERATION. AWARENESS WEEK,
SENATOR JONES, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
FILE ITEM SEVEN, WHICH IS S¼ èC
R 116 FOT TEMPORAL GENERATION IS
A TERMINAL AND INCURABLE
NEURODEGENERATIVE DISEASE. IT
CAUSES IMPAIRMENTS TO SPEECH,
PERSONALITY, BEHAVIOR AND MOTOR.
SKILLS FRONTAL TEMPORAL
DEGENERATION PRIMARILY AFFECTS
INDIVIDUALS IN THEIR FORTIES TO
SIXTIES BUT HAS BEEN DIAGNOSED
IN INDIVIDUALS AS YOUNG AS 14.
THE DISEASE ACCOUNTS TO 5 TO 15%
OF ALL DEMENTIA CASES AND
EFFECTS. AN ESTIMATED 60,000
PEOPLE IN THE IN THE U S¼.
DESPITE ITS PREVALENCE, IT IS
OFTEN MISDIAGNOSED AND
OVERLOOKED DUE TO ITS WIDE RANGE
OF SYMPTOMS AND LACK OF
AWARENESS AMONG THE PUBLIC AND
HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONALS FO
TEMPORAL DEGENERATION AWARENESS
WEEK IS CRUCIAL AS IT SHINES A
SPOTLIGHT ON THIS OFTEN
MISUNDERSTOOD DISEASE AND
EMPHASIZES THE IMPORTANCE OF
EARLY DETECTION, ACCURATE
DIAGNOSIS AND ACCESS TO
APPROPRIATE CARE AND SUPPORT
SERVICES. ASK THAT WE ALL? UH
SUPPORT TODAY. UH S¼ èC R 116.
THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT. THANK
YOU, SENATOR JONES. ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS RESOLUTION
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION? NÓ
MICROPHONES UP. THIS IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. BUT
THAT OBJECTIONS EYES 40. NÓ
ZERO. THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
WE'RE GONNA MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM EIGHT. THIS IS S¼ R 67 BY
SENATOR DODD. HE'S PREPARED
SECRETARY. PLEASE READ SENATE
RESOLUTION 67 BY SENATOR DODD
REGISTERED TO NATIONAL GAMBLING
AWARENESS MONTH, SENATOR DODD.
THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS
AS CHAIR OF THE SENATE GE Ó
COMMITTEE. I'M PROUD TO PRESENT
THE STATE RESOLUTION 67, WHICH
RECOGNIZES MARCH 2024 AS PROBLEM
GAMBLING AWARENESS MONTH IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. ALTHOUGH
MOST PEOPLE ARE ABLE TO GAMBLE
RESPONSIBLY. FOR SOME, IT
BECOMES A DEVASTATING ADDICTION
THAT AFFECTS NOT ONLY THE
INDIVIDUAL BUT THEIR LOVED ONES.
FORTUNATELY GAMBLING ADDICTION
IS TREATABLE. THAT IS WHY DURING
THE MONTH OF MARCH,
ORGANIZATIONS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE COME TOGETHER TO EDUCATE
THE PUBLIC IN HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS ABOUT THE WARNING
SIGNS OF PROBLEM GAMING. THIS
RESOLUTION WILL RAISE AWARENESS
ABOUT THAT THE HELP THAT IS
AVAILABLE BOTH LOCALLY AND
NATIONALLY FOR PROBLEM GAMBLERS
AND THEIR FAMILIES. I WANT TO
THANK THE MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
COMMITTEE FOR CO-AUTHOR IN THIS
RESOLUTION. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR I VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR
DODD ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION ON
THE RESOLUTION ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION? NÓ. THIS IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. NÓ
OBJECTIONS. AYS 40 NÓ ZEROS. THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. WE'RE
GONNA MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM. 12
THIS IS S¼ R 70 BY SENATOR
ATKINS. SECRETARY. PLEASE READ
SENATE RESOLUTION 70 BY SENATOR
ATKINS RELATIVE TO TRANSGENDER
DAY OF VISIBILITY. SENATOR
ATKINS. THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES ARE ROD TODAY TO
PRESENT S¼ R 70, WHICH
CELEBRATES TRANSGENDER WEEK OF
VISIBILITY IN THE CAPITOL AND
PROCLAIMING MARCH 31ST AS
TRANSGENDER DAY OF VISIBILITY.
COMMEMORATED EACH YEAR, THE
INTERNATIONAL TRANSGENDER DAY OF
VISIBILITY ENCOMPASSES AN
EXPANSIVE COMMUNITY OF PEOPLE
WHO IDENTIFY AS TWO SPIRIT,
TRANSGENDER, GENDER, NON
CONFORMING OR NON BINARY OR
INTERSEX. UH, IF YOU'RE KEEPING
TRACK OF THE INITIALS THAT WOULD
BE TWO S¼ Tð G  N. I èC AND
WHILE OUR L GB, Tð Q PLUS CAUCUS
AND OUR COMMUNITY AS WELL AS OUR
ALLIES, HONOR THE TRANSGENDER
DAY OF REMEMBRANCE, WHICH IS A
PAINFUL DAY, WHERE WE
MEMORIALIZE OUR TRANS SIBLINGS
WE'VE LOST DUE TO TRANS HATE AND
GENDER VIOLENCE. IT'S CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE ALSO
COMMEMORATE TRANSGENDER DAY OF
VISIBILITY TO CELEBRATE OUR TWO
S¼ Tð G AND I èC SIBLINGS WITH
JOY WITH HOPE AND WITH SUPPORT.
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE L GB
Tð Q CAUCUS REAFFIRMS ITS
UNWAVERING SUPPORT TO OUR TWO
SPIRIT, TRANSGENDER GENDER, NON
CONFORMING NON-BINARY AND
INTERSEX SIBLINGS. OUR COMMUNITY
IS UNITED IN OUR PURSUIT FOR
EQUITY AND EQUALITY FOR ALL
PEOPLE. OUR CAUCUS IS PROUD TO
HIGHLIGHT THE REPRESENTATION OF
THE Tð G. I COMMUNITY IN ELECTED
OFFICES NATIONWIDE WITH MORE
THAN 98 OFFICIALS THAT WE KNOW
OF, INCLUDING NON IN CALIFORNIA,
SUCH AS, UH, ONE OF MY OWN, UH,
SUPERVISORS IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY,
TARA LAWSON REMER. AND OF COURSE
, WE'VE ALL HEARD AND SEEN THE
NATIONAL WORK, UH, OF LISA
MIDDLETON, WHO SERVES ON THE
PALM SPRINGS CITY COUNCIL. NOW
MORE THAN EVER. IT'S CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE CELEBRATE
DURING THIS WEEK AND FURTHER
AFFIRM OUR SUPPORT FOR OUR TRANS
SIBLINGS AND THE RIGHT TO LIVE
VISIBLY OPENLY, AUTHENTICALLY
AND UNAPOLOGETICALLY. SO
COLLEAGUES. THANK YOU. I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I VOTE
ON S¼ R 70 REAFFIRMING OUR
SUPPORT FOR OUR COMMUNITY
MEMBERS. THANK YOU, SENATOR
ATKINS. I SEE MICROPHONES UP
FROM SENATOR PADILLA AND WIENER.
SENATOR PADILLA. THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE LATINO CAUCUS IN SUPPORT
OF S¼ R 70 TO CELEBRATE OUR
TRANSGENDER SIBLINGS AND
TRANSGENDER DAY AND WEEK OF
VISIBILITY. CELEBRATIONS LIKE
THIS, GIVE US AN OPPORTUNITY TO
UPLIFT THE VOICES AND THE
STORIES OF PEOPLE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES WORKING TO MAKE THIS
STATE MORE EQUITABLE FOR ALL
STORIES OF PEOPLE LIKE BAMBI
SALCEDO, AN ACTIVIST KNOWN FOR
HER PASSIONATE ADVOCACY AS THE
èC E Ó OF THE TRANS LATIN
COALITION, WHICH HAS WORKED TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUES OF THE
TRANSGENDER LATINA COMMUNITY
THROUGHOUT THE NATION, OR THE
STORY OF ADELA VASQUEZ, A CUBAN
TRANSGENDER HÌ. I VÆ A I Dð S¼
ACTIVIST. WORK SUPPORTING
TRANSWOMEN BATTLING AIDS. HAS
BEEN INSTRUMENTAL IN SAN
FRANCISCO SINCE THE EARLY 19
EIGHTIES. THERE ARE SO MANY
STORIES OF COMMUNITY AND
PROGRESS THAT HAPPEN EVERY DAY
IN THE STATE STORIES OF OUR
NEIGHBORS AND FAMILY, WORKING TO
MAKE A BETTER LIFE FOR
THEMSELVES AND THEIR LOVED ONES.
BUT WHILE WE CELEBRATE WE CANNOT
IGNORE THE SAD AND ALARMING RISE
OF OPEN AGGRESSION AND BIGOTRY.
DIRECTED AT THE L GB Tð Q
COMMUNITY THROUGHOUT OUR COUNTRY
, ESPECIALLY TOWARDS TRANS
CHILDREN. EVERY DAY IN THIS
COUNTRY. TRANS RIGHTS ARE UNDER
ATTACK AS EXTREMISTS TRY TO
SLANDER, SHAME AND EVEN
PHYSICALLY ATTACK TRANS
INDIVIDUALS FOR SIMPLY EXISTING
THIS YEAR ALONE. OVER 400 PIECES
OF ANTI TRANS ANTI L GB Tð Q
LEGISLATION HAVE BEEN INTRODUCED
IN CITY HALLS AND STATEHOUSES.
AND EVEN IN OUR NATION'S
CAPITAL. THERE ARE THOSE THAT
SEEK TO STRIP MEMBERS OF THE
COMMUNITY OF THEIR DIGNITY.
INDEED THEIR HUMANITY ONE RIGHT
AT A TIME. HARVEY MILK SAID THAT
WHEN THE L GB Tð Q COMMUNITY
STAYS IN THE SHADOW WE
PERPETUATE OUR INVISIBILITY AND
HE WAS RIGHT. WHICH IS WHY
RECOGNITIONS AND
ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS ARE VISIBLE. AN
IMPORTANT AND VITAL TRANS DAY
AND WEEK OF VISIBILITY ARE A WAY
FOR US TO DEMONSTRATE OUR
SUPPORT. AND OUR TRANS
COMMUNITIES BECAUSE THEY DESERVE
HAPPINESS, SAFETY AND THE
ABILITY TO LIVE OPENLY. IS THERE
TRUE AND AUTHENTIC SELVES. WE
MUST DEDICATE OURSELVES FRANKLY,
COLLEAGUES. TO THE WORK OF
EDUCATING AND FOSTERING
UNDERSTANDING. WE HAVE TO LIFT
UP THE BEATING HEARTS. OF EVERY
HUMAN BEING. AS PRECIOUS AND
BUILD MORE DIRECT. HUMAN
CONDITIONS AND CONNECTIONS. IT
REMAINS A BASIC HUMAN TRAIT. WE
FEAR WHAT WE DON'T UNDERSTAND
AND FEAR OFTEN DEVOLVES INTO
HATRED. IT IS OUR DUTY. TO HELP
OTHERS SEE THE HUMANITY. IN ONE
ANOTHER. COLLEAGUES ARE
RESPECTFULLY ASKED FOR AN I
VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR
PADILLA. NEXT ONE. I RECOGNIZE
SENATOR WEINER, FOLLOWED BY
SENATOR BRADFORD, SENATOR
WEINER. HM? THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT. UH, COLLEAGUES. I
RISE TODAY AS CO-CHAIR OF THE
LEGISLATIVE JEWISH CAUCUS AS A
GÂY MAN AND AS A STAUNCH
SUPPORTER OF OUR TRANS COMMUNITY
AND SUPPORT OF S¼ R 70. AT A
TIME WHEN THE TRANS COMMUNITY IS
UNDER ATTACK ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
UH, IT'S OF UTMOST IMPORTANCE
THAT WE RECOGNIZE AND REAFFIRM
THAT TRANS PEOPLE ARE LOVED,
SEEN AND ENTITLED TO THE SAME
DECENCY AND RESPECT. ME AS
ANYONE ELSE. WE MUST TAKE ACTION
TO PROTECT OUR TRANS SIBLINGS
AND MAKE CLEAR THAT WE WILL NOT
ABANDON THEM. SORRY. UH, WITHIN
THE JEWISH TRADITION, THERE'S A
RICH HISTORY OF TRANSGENDER
RECOGNITION. UH, JEWISH
LEGALISTIC TRADITION RECOGNIZES
SIX GENDERS AND THE FLUIDITY
AMONG THEM. TOM AND KABBALISTIC
STUDY, IDENTIFY IMPORTANT
FIGURES WITHIN OUR FAITH AS
LIVING THEIR LIVES IN WAYS. THAT
MIGHT BE CONSIDERED TRANS OR
NON-BINARY IN MODERN TERMS. EVEN
AS WE CELEBRATE THIS COMMUNITY.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE THAT
TRANS PEOPLE, PARTICULARLY TRANS
WOMEN OF COLOR ARE MORE LIKELY
TO EXPERIENCE VIOLENCE. UH, THAT
VIOLENCE MUST BE RECOGNIZED AND
CALLED OUT. SO THAT WE DON'T
LOSE ANY MORE OF OUR TRANS
SIBLINGS. LAST YEAR WAS THE
DEADLIEST YEAR EVER ON RECORD
FOR THE TRANS COMMUNITY
SOMETHING I HOPE I NEVER NEED TO
SAY AGAIN. AND WE MUST CONDEMN
THE WAY THE TRANS KIDS ARE
CRUELLY VICIOUSLY AND CYNICALLY
USED TO SCORE POLITICAL POINTS.
THESE ATTACKS HAVE REAL
CONSEQUENCES. WHEN TREATMENT IS
DENIED LIVES ARE LOST. 81% OF
TRANS INDIVIDUALS HAVE
CONSIDERED AND 42% HAVE
ATTEMPTED SUICIDE. THAT NUMBER
IS 56% AMONG TRANS YOUTH ALMOST
630% OF THE RATE AMONG THE
ENTIRE YOUTH POPULATION IN TERMS
OF ATTEMPTING SUICIDE. 56% OF
TRANS ADULTS HAVE ENGAGED IN NON
SUICIDAL SELF INJURY IN THEIR
LIFETIME. UH, NEXT. BENEDICT IS
JUST THE LATEST INCIDENT
INSTANCE IN WHICH WE HAVE SEEN
VILE RHETORIC AND BULLYING AND
INTIMIDATION AGAINST THE TRANS
COMMUNITY TURN INTO REAL LIFE
HARM. CHILDREN ARE LOSING THEIR
LIVES BECAUSE OF THE HEAT PREACH
AGAINST THEM. LET'S BE CLEAR
THAT PLAYING POLITICAL GAMES
WITH PEOPLE'S LIVES IS
DESPICABLE AND MUST NEVER BE THE
NORM IN AMERICAN POLITICS.
WHETHER IT'S BAD FAITH BATHROOM
BILLS. OR THOSE SEEKING TO
DISCRIMINATE. OUR VOICES MUST BE
CLEAR. THERE IS NÓ PLACE FOR
THIS DISGUSTING AND DEADLY
HATRED IN OUR COMMUNITY. THESE
GROUPS AND INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
ENGAGING IN THIS DEADLY FORM OF
POLITICS TOWARDS TRANS PEOPLE.
THEY'RE NOT ACTUALLY INTERESTED
IN REALITY. THE FACTS THAT THEY
CLAIM ARE OFTEN NOT TRUE. UH,
AND ARE SIMPLY COVER FOR BIGOTRY
. THEY'RE WEAPONIZING, HATE AND
DISCOMFORT TO ENGAGE IN A
MYTHOLOGICAL CULTURE WAR THAT
DISTRACTS FROM THE TRUE CRIMES
AND VIOLENCE ACTUALLY BEING
COMMITTED AGAINST TRANS PEOPLE
IN OUR SOCIETY. THEY TREAT TRANS
PEOPLE AS IF THEY'RE NOT FULL.
HUMAN BEINGS AS IF THEY'RE JUST
MAKING IT UP. AS IF THEY'RE JUST
TRYING TO SCAM THEIR WAY INTO A
SPACE WHERE THEY ACCORDING TO
THESE FOLKS SHOULDN'T BE UM, IS
IT ANY WONDER THAT THE TRANS
COMMUNITY STRUGGLES WHEN DAY IN
AND DAY OUT THEY HAVE TO LISTEN
TO THAT KIND OF VILE,
DEHUMANIZING RHETORIC? THE
JEWISH COMMUNITY, UH, ACCORDING
TO SURVEYS HAS BEEN MORE
ACCEPTING OF TRANS PEOPLE AND
GENDER, DIVERSE PEOPLE THAN ANY
OTHER GROUP. I'M PROUD OF OUR
TRANS COMMUNITY. I'M PROUD OF
OUR JEWISH COMMUNITY. UH AND I
AM PROUD TO VOTE I ON S¼ R 70.
THANK YOU, SENATOR WEINER,
SENATOR BRADFORD. THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT. HIS VICE CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS. I SUPPORT S¼ R 70
RECOGNIZING MARCH 31ST 2024 AS
TRANSGENDER DAY OF VISIBILITY,
AND THIS WEEK AS TRAN
TRANSGENDER WEEK OF VISIBILITY,
IT IS IMPORTANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT MEMBERS OF THE TRANS GENDER
COMMUNITY HAVE OVERCOME MANY
OBSTACLES AND CHALLENGES TO
BUILD A PLACE FOR THEMSELVES.
THESE OBSTACLES INCLUDE MENTAL
AND PHYSICAL HARASSMENT,
DISCRIMINATION AND ATTACKS ON
THEIR VERY IDENTITY, BLACK,
TRANSGENDER AND NON BINARY YOUTH
, IN PARTICULAR EXPERIENCE, A
UNIQUE SET OF CHALLENGES BECAUSE
OF THE INTERSECTION BETWEEN
THEIR RACE AND THEIR GENDER
IDENTITY. 77% OF BLACK, TRANS
TRANSGENDER AND NON BINARY YOUTH
SUFFER DISCRIMINATION BASED ON
THEIR GENDER, GENDER IDENTITY.
40% OF THEM HAVE BEEN PHYSICALLY
THREATENED OR HARMED BECAUSE OF
THEIR GENDER IDENTITY. THESE
NUMBERS SHOW THAT WE MUST ALL DO
, UH, TO WHAT WE MUST ALL DO TO
MAKE OUR STATE AND OUR COUNTRY A
MORE WELCOMING AND ACCEPTING
PLACE. WE CAN CONTINUE TO LOOK
AT THE EXAMPLE SET BY PEOPLE
LIKE MARSHA P JOHNSON, WHO WAS A
CENTRAL FIGURE OF THE STONEWALL
UPRISING, AND MISS MAJOR GRIFFIN
. GRACIE WHO LED TO SAN
FRANCISCO BASED TRANSGENDER
VARIANT AND INTERSEX JUSTICE
PROJECT TO ADVOCATE FOR
INCARCERATED TRANS WOMEN. I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK OUR
PRESIDENT PRO TEM EMERITUS
ATKINS FOR BRINGING THIS MEASURE
FORWARD, AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR I VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR
BRADFORD. I HAVE A MICROPHONE UP
FROM SENATOR LAIRD, FOLLOWED BY
SENATOR SKINNER, SENATOR LAIRD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR
PRESIDENT. UH, THERE WAS A TIME,
UH, EARLY IN MY OWN CAREER,
WHEREAS ONE OF THE FEW OUT
ELECTED OFFICIALS. IF YOU CAN
BELIEVE IT. I HAD MANY
CONSTITUENTS THAT THOUGHT I WAS
THE ONLY GÂY PERSON THEY KNEW.
UH IT'S BECAUSE THERE WERE LOTS
THERE. BUT THAT WASN'T TRUE. AND
THEY WEREN'T OUT TO THEM. AND IT
TOOK THIS CHANGING. OF PEOPLE
REALIZING WHO WAS AROUND THEM
AND WHAT THE COMMUNITY WAS TO
SORT OF GET. WHAT THE REAL L GB
Tð COMMUNITY WAS AND TO GET THE
STRUGGLES THAT ACTUALLY WERE
GOING ON. THAT WAS THE REASON
THAT THEY DIDN'T THINK THERE
WERE MANY OTHER PEOPLE AROUND
THEM. AND AS WE ADVANCE TO
DISCUSS DISCUSSING THIS
RESOLUTION AND THE SUBJECT OF
TRANS PEOPLE, IT IS VERY
SIMILAR. IT IS VERY SIMILAR IN
THAT PEOPLE DO NOT UNDERSTAND
WHO'S AROUND THEM. BUT I HAD
THIS EXPERIENCE. THAT WAS, UH,
YOU KNOW, ALL OF US HAVE HAD TO
UNDERSTAND AND LEARN. I AM AMONG
THE OLDER MEMBERS HERE. FOR THE
1ST 20 OR 30 YEARS OF MY LIFE.
IT NEVER OCCURRED TO ME ONCE I
HAD MENTALLY PROGRAMMED
SOMEBODY'S GENDER THAT I HAD TO
ADJUST IN HOW I ADDRESSED THEM,
AND I HAVE SOMEONE WHO IS A
STAFF MEMBER IN THE ASSEMBLY. UH
UH, WHEN I WAS IN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THAT TRANSITIONED THAT IS
NOW AN ELECTED OFFICIAL IN SANTA
CRUZ COUNTY AND I. I AM
MORTIFIED TO CONFESS THAT FOR
THE FIRST YEAR, I WOULD SLIP
PERIODICALLY A AND CALL HIM SHE
UNTIL I TOTALLY REPROGRAMMED IN
A WAY THAT I WASN'T USED TO
HAVING TO DO. AND THAT IS TRUE
FOR FAMILIES AND THERE'S
SOMEBODY IN MY COMMUNITY THAT IS
A MEMBER OF THE L GB Tð
COMMUNITY THAT IN HER OWN RIGHT
WAS AN INCREDIBLE TRAILBLAZER. A
LEADER, UH, ASCENDED TO A
POSITION THAT THAT, UH, NOT MANY
WOMEN HAD EVER ASCENDED TO IN
THE LAW ENFORCEMENT RANKS, AND
SHE AND HER PARTNER HAVE A FEW
KIDS. AND THIS ONE KIDS DOING
REALLY WELL IN SCHOOL AND THEN
GETS FOR TWO OR THREE YEARS.
IT'S LIKE REALLY CRASHING. AND
THEY GO TO COUNSELING AND THEY
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS THE
ISSUE. AND THAT KID GRADUALLY
STARTS TO ADJUST. TO WHO THEY
THINK THEY ARE, AND THEY ARE
SUCCEEDING IN SCHOOL. THEY ARE
DOING REALLY WELL. AND IT WAS
INTERESTING BECAUSE THE PARENTS
HAD TO MAKE THE ADJUSTMENT JUST
AS MUCH AS THE KID HAD TO MAKE
THE ADJUSTMENT. AND SO I TALK
ABOUT THESE BECAUSE THEN WE HAVE
THE LAWS THAT WERE REFERRED TO
AND IT'S SORT OF AT A VERY HIGH
LEVEL, POLITICIZING THIS
SITUATION AND TRYING TO FORCE
PEOPLE INTO WHETHER IT'S
BATHROOMS OR BEDROOMS OR
FAMILIES WHEN IT'S INDIVIDUAL,
STRUGGLING TO SORT OF DO WHAT IS
RIGHT FOR THEM. IT IS FAMILY
STRUGGLING TO DO WHAT'S RIGHT
FOR THE INDIVIDUAL, AND IT'S UP
TO US IN THE AWARENESS AND
RECOGNITION TO MAKE SURE WE
ALLOW FOR THAT TO HAPPEN IN A
GOOD, POSITIVE, CONSTRUCTIVE WAY
. AND I THINK THIS RESOLUTION IS
PART OF THAT DISCUSSION. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IPHONE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR LAIRD,
SENATOR SKINNER. THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT. MEMBER I RISE AS THE
CHAIR OF THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS IN
SUPPORT OF S¼ R 70. I GREATLY
APPRECIATE THE VERY ELOQUENT
COMMENTS BY OUR COLLEAGUES THAT
I PROBABLY WOULD, UH, NOT BE
ABLE TO ARTICULATE AS WELL. BUT
I WANTED TO GIVE THANKS TO THE
TEXT OF THE RESOLUTION IN THAT.
IT CITES THESE HISTORICAL, UM
REAL THINGS IN WITHIN OUR
CULTURAL HISTORY. AND WITHIN THE
CANONS OF OUR WESTERN
CIVILIZATION. WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE, UH, GREEK AND ROMAN AND THE
OTHER, UH, CITATIONS THAT ARE
MADE IN S¼ R 70, OF COURSE TO
OUR COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO'S REFERENCE TO THE
TRADITION, THE JEWISH TRADITION
IN THE TORAH AND THE, UM OTHER
STUDIES THAT THIS ARE THE
POLITICAL FIXATION NOW. DENIES
THE FACT THAT THIS. HAS BEEN A
REALITY WITHIN OUR HUMAN CULTURE
FROM DAY ONE. AND HAS BEEN BY
MOST CULTURES ACCEPTED. AND IT
HAS BEEN MUCH MORE RECENTLY
WHERE WE HAVE TRIED TO
CATEGORIZE PEOPLE IN SUCH A WAY
THAT WE THEN MISTREAT THEM
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST THEM AND
OTHER HORRIBLE CONSEQUENCES
WHERE THEY FEEL THEY CAN HAVE NÓ
FEELINGS OF SELF WORTH AND SELF
CONFIDENCE, WHICH IS THE
ABSOLUTE WORST THING TO DO TO
ANY PERSON. SO AS A WOMAN'S
CAUCUS CHAIR. I STAND IN. GREAT
THANKS THAT THIS IS BEING
BROUGHT BEFORE US, AND I ALSO AM
VERY PROUD TO REPRESENT A
DISTRICT THAT HAS REALLY BEEN AT
THE FOREFRONT OF MANY OF THESE
ISSUES. WE WERE THE FIRST AREA
THAT I AM AWARE OF, UM, TO HAVE
ELECTED AND OPENLY TRANS PERSON
WHEN IN 2010. WE ELECTED VICKY
KOWSKE AS A JUDGE. AND WE ALSO
HAVE HAD, UM OUR TRANS COMMUNITY
HAS HELD A PUBLIC VIGIL TO READ
THE NAMES OUT LOUD OF EVERY
TRANS PERSON THAT DIED IN THAT
YEAR, AND THEY HAVE BEEN HOLDING
THAT PUBLIC VIGIL SINCE EARLIER
THAN 2008. SO I AM SO PROUD TO
REPRESENT A DISTRICT LIKE THAT,
AND WE AND I'M ALSO PROUD THAT
CULTURALLY NOW WHEN WE LOOK AT
WHETHER IT'S OUR, YOU KNOW, AND
SOME STEREOTYPES, BUT WHETHER WE
LOOK AT Tð VÆ SHOWS, UM UH,
MOVIES AND SUCH LIKE THAT THAT
THEY'RE IN ENTERTAINMENT, THERE
IS MUCH MORE ACCEPTANCE OF TRANS
PEOPLE AND PROJECTION OF TRANS
PEOPLE AGAIN WITH, UNFORTUNATELY
SOME STEREOTYPES IN CERTAIN
CASES, BUT MUCH MORE A
REFLECTION OF WHAT WE SHOULD ALL
BE WELCOMING AND ENGAGED IN
RATHER THAN THE POLITICALIZATION
AND THE DEMEANING THAT WE SEE
TOO OFTEN, AND WE SEE SO MANY
OTHER IN ENGAGING IN THE LAWS
THAT THEY'VE PASSED. SO AGAIN. I
THINK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD AND I URGE AND I
VOTE ON S¼ R 70. THANK YOU,
SENATOR SKINNER. I NOW RECOGNIZE
SENATOR JONES. MR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS MEMBERS. I JUST WANTED
TO RISE BRIEFLY AND EXPLAIN WHY
I'LL BE VOTING NÓ ON S¼ R 70.
WELL, I KNOW THIS IS A VERY
PERSONAL, UH, DECISION BY EACH
ONE OF ALL 40 OF US HERE ON THE
SENATE FLOOR. UH AND THERE'S
MANY THINGS IN THIS RESOLUTION
THAT ARE SUPPORTABLE, AND I ALSO
WANT TO AGREE WITH OUR
COLLEAGUES THAT HAVE RAISED THE
CONCERN OF THE CULTURE WAR AND
THE HATE FILLED SPEECH AND
TREATMENT THAT ARE TRANS
COMMUNITIES EXPER ACROSS THE
UNITED STATES, AND CERTAINLY I
DO NOT SUPPORT ANY OF THOSE
WORDS AND OR ACTIONS THAT ARE
MET IN A HATEFUL, DEMEANING OR,
UH ANYWAYS. SUCH AS THAT. THE
CHALLENGE I HAVE IS I HAVE THREE
CHILDREN. I HAVE TWO BOYS AND A
GIRL. MY GIRL IS IN THE MIDDLE.
ALL THREE OF THEM PLAY HAD
PLAYED COLLEGIATE LEVEL
VOLLEYBALL. MY BOYS ARE 6 FT.
FOUR. MY DAUGHTER IS 5 FT FOUR.
MOST FEMALE COLLEGE VOLLEYBALL
PLAYERS ARE 6 FT. TALL. OR
TALLER. MOST MALE COLLEGE
VOLLEYBALL PLAYERS ARE 6 FT
SEVEN OR TALLER. AND WHEN WE ARE
SEEING THE IMPACTS ON FEMALE
SPORTS AROUND THIS COUNTRY, BOTH
AT THE HIGH SCHOOL LEVEL AND THE
COLLEGE LEVEL. THE REFERENCE THE
BRIEF REFERENCE, UH TO SPORTS IN
THE RESOLUTION IS WHAT IS
CAUSING ME TO VOTE NÓ TODAY AND,
UH, APPRECIATE, UH, THE ABILITY
TO BE ABLE TO SHARE THOSE
SENTIMENTS TODAY, BUT I THINK
WE'VE GOT TO COME TO A PLACE
WHERE WE'RE PROTECTING WOMEN AND
WOMEN'S SPORTS AND ALLOW WOMEN
TO ACCOMPLISH, UH, EVERY DREAM
THAT THEY HAVE SET OUT SINCE
THEY WERE LITTLE GIRLS TO
COMPETE AT THOSE LEVELS AND BE
ABLE TO WIN AND WIN THE PRIZE
THAT THEY WORKED FOR. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. SENATOR MIN. THANK
YOU, MR PRESIDENT, AS VICE CHAIR
OF THE API LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS. I
WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN DIEGO FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD. UH, THIS IS SUCH AN
IMPORTANT BILL. THE MESSAGE IT
SENDS IS SO IMPORTANT. UH, WE
OBVIOUSLY LIVE IN A TIME WHEN
THERE IS JUST RAMPANT HATE OF
ALL KINDS. UH, MY COMMUNITY HAS
SEEN A SPIKE IN ANTI ASIAN HATE,
UH, HAS LEFT MANY MEMBERS OF MY
COMMUNITY FEELING, UH,
VULNERABLE. SCARED UH, WE'VE
SEEN A RISE IN ANTI-BLACK HATE,
UH, ISLAMOPHOBIA AND ANTI
SEMITISM, BUT WE KNOW THAT ANTI
TRANS HATE IS THE MOST VITRIOLIC
, MOST VIOLENT AND THE MOST
PERVASIVE IN OUR SOCIETY. UH AND
WE NEED TO STAND TOGETHER. AND
SO ON ON BEHALF OF THE API
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS, I WANT TO
SAY TO THE TRANS COMMUNITY OUT
THERE WE SEE YOU. WE RECOGNIZE
YOUR STRUGGLES. WE STAND WITH
YOU BECAUSE WE ARE BETTER AND
STRONGER WHEN WE STAND TOGETHER
AGAINST HATE. AND YES, EVEN IN
CALIFORNIA WE SEE TOO MUCH HATE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR.
MIN. SENATOR GROVE. THANK YOU,
MR PRESIDENT. I TOO RESPECTFULLY
RISE. UM IN OPPOSITION OF S¼ R
70. I'D LIKE TO ECHO SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES COMMENTS THAT WERE
SAID, YOU KNOW, THERE'S NÓ ROOM
FOR HATE. THERE'S NÓ ROOM FOR
THE PERSECUTION OF INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE TRANSGENDER OR JEWISH OR
WHITE OR BLACK OR ASIAN. THERE'S
NÓ ROOM FOR THAT, UM, IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA, AND I THINK
THAT YOU KNOW, UM TAKES ME BACK
TO A LITTLE, UH, SONG WHEN I WAS
IN BIBLE SCHOOL, YOU KNOW, IT'S
LIKE IN YELLOW, BLACK AND WHITE.
THEY ARE PRECIOUS IN HIS SIGHT.
AND WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT JUST
TREATING PEOPLE WITH DECENCY AND
RESPECT, BUT I DO THINK THAT THE
LANGUAGE IN THE RESOLUTION DOES
TAKE IT FURTHER THAN IT DID LAST
YEAR. WHEN YOU LOOK AT
TRANSGENDERISM AND YOU HAVE TO
THINK ABOUT OUR BIOLOGICAL GIRLS
THAT ARE COMPETING AGAINST
BIOLOGICAL MALES. THEY'RE ALSO
HAVING TO DRESS IN DRESSING
ROOMS OF BIOLOGICAL MALES. YOU
GET OUR BIOLOGICAL FEMALES THAT
ARE IN GRADE SCHOOL AND HIGH
SCHOOL ARE, UM, GETTING HURT,
BECAUSE LET'S JUST FACE IT,
LADIES. I MEAN, WE REALLY GOOD
AT WHAT WE DO, BUT BIOLOGICAL
MALES ARE JUST A LOT OF TIMES
MORE STRONGER THAN US, AND
ESPECIALLY IN AN ADOLESCENT
WORLD. UM LIKE I SAID, I DON'T
THINK THERE'S ANY ROOM FOR HATE.
I DON'T THINK THERE'S ANY ROOM
FOR ACCUSATIONS OR FEAR AND ALL
OF THOSE THINGS. I THINK THERE
SHOULD BE A SAFE SPACE BUT THERE
FOR TRANSGENDER, UH, INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE GO WHO ARE CHOOSING THAT
OR OR OR IN IN SOME CASES BY MY
COLLEAGUES, DEFINITIONS DESIGNED
BY THAT, BUT I JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT YOU WE HAVE TO ALSO CREATE
A SAFE SPACE FOR OUR BIOLOGICAL
FEMALES THAT ARE STRUGGLING IN
ALL OF OUR DISTRICTS. AND THAT'S
EVIDENT WITH THE POLL THAT JUST
CAME OUT THAT 64% OF CALIFORNIA
VOTERS BELIEVE THAT BIOLOGICAL
MALES SHOULD NOT BE PLAY SPORTS
WITH BIOLOGICAL FEMALES. BECAUSE
THERE ARE SOME OF OUR GIRLS ARE
BEING BRUTALLY HURT IN THESE
SITUATIONS, BECAUSE IT'S JUST A
FACT THAT MALES ARE OBVIOUSLY
STRONGER, UM THAN FEMALES. AND
SO JUST WITH THAT IN THE
RESOLUTION, RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN A NÓ. MEMBERS ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. THE SECOND
TIME, SENATOR WEINER. I THANK
YOU, MR PRESIDENT. I WASN'T
PLANNING OBVIOUSLY TO SPEAK A
SECOND TIME, BUT SOME COMMENTS
WERE MADE THAT I THINK NEED, UM,
A RESPONSE. UH, PARTICULARLY
ABOUT TRANSGENDER KIDS, UH, WHO
SIMPLY WANT TO PLAY SPORTS?
SOMETHING THAT KIDS WANT TO DO,
UH, AND ARE BEING TOLD BY
POLITICIANS. NÓ YOU'RE NOT
ALLOWED, UH TO PLAY, UH, SPORTS.
UH WE NEED TO BE VERY CLEAR THAT
THE NARRATIVE THAT'S BEING
PAINTED AROUND TRANS KIDS
PLAYING SPORTS AS IF IT'S A
BUNCH OF LEBRON'S. GOING TO THE
LOCAL HIGH SCHOOL TO PLAY THE
HIGH SCHOOL KIDS. THAT'S WHAT
THEY PAINT IT AS AND WE KNOW
THAT THAT IS NOT WHAT IS
ACTUALLY HAPPENING IN THE REAL
WORLD, AND SO MANY OF THESE
TRANS KIDS MAY NOT EVEN BE VERY
GOOD AT SPORTS, JUST LIKE YOU
KNOW, MANY OF US MAY HAVE BEEN
NOT VERY GOOD AT PARTICULAR
SPORTS THAT WE WANTED TO PLAY.
UH AND THEY AND THEY'RE NOT
DOMINATING. AND THERE ARE PLENTY
OF EXAMPLES OF TRANS KIDS WHO
COMPETE. AND DON'T DO WELL AND
FINISH AN EIGHT OR 10 TO 12TH
PLACE THAT DOESN'T MAKE THE
PRESS. THAT DOESN'T GET BLASTED
OUT ON SOCIAL MEDIA. THERE WAS
ONE FAMOUS SITUATION. A SWIMMER
FROM KENTUCKY. WHO COMPLAINED
THAT A TRANS WOMAN TIED HER AND
BECAUSE OF A TIEBREAKER CAME IN
AHEAD OF HER. WHAT SHE NEGLECTS
TO MENTION IS THAT THEY TIED FOR
SIXTH PLACE BECAUSE FIVE
CISGENDER WOMEN FINISHED AHEAD.
OF THE TRANS WOMAN WHO WAS
SWIMMING AND THAT BECAME A CAUSE
CELEBRE. AS SOME SORT OF
ARGUMENT AGAINST TRANS
PARTICIPATION IN SPORTS. THERE
ARE KIDS IN GENERAL, AND
PARTICULARLY TRANS KIDS, THEY
JUST WANT TO LIVE THEIR LIVES.
AND SOME TRANS KID IN THE
MIDWEST WHO JUST WANTS TO RUN
CROSS COUNTRY AND DOESN'T WANNA
HAVE PEOPLE HAVE TO EXAMINE
THEIR GENITALIA BECAUSE THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT THEY'RE TRYING TO
REQUIRE. IMAGINE SOME, LIKE 13
YEAR OLD WHO JUST WANTS TO RUN
CROSS COUNTRY. AND NOW HAS TO
SUBMIT TO SOME HUMILIATING
PHYSICAL EXAMINATION BECAUSE
POLITICIANS HAVE DECIDED THAT
THAT'S WHAT'S NECESSARY. DO YOU
WONDER WHY THESE KIDS ARE IN
SUCH A BAD PLACE, THE CONSTANT
ATTACKS AND WE KNOW YES, THE
POLLING SHOWS YOU CAN BECAUSE WE
KNOW HOW IT WORKS. THAT AFTER
THE RIGHT WING LOST THE BATTLE
ON MARRIAGE EQUALITY THAT WAS NÓ
LONGER A WINNING ISSUE. THEY DID
FOCUS GROUPS AND EVALUATION AND
DECIDED WHAT'S THE NEXT GROUP
THAT WE CAN TARGET? IT WAS TRANS
KIDS AND WE KNOW FROM THE
POLLING. TRANS KIDS IN SPORTS.
THAT IS THAT CAN BE A STRONG
ISSUE FOR THE HARD RIGHT. SO BE
IT. SO BE IT. WE HAVE TO DO WHAT
THE RIGHT THING IS, WHICH IS
MAKING SURE THAT THESE KIDS ARE
ABLE TO BE WHO THEY ARE LIVE
THEIR LIVES, PLAY WHATEVER
SPORTS THEY WANNA PLAY AND JUST
LEAVE THEM ALONE. SENATOR SARTO.
THANK YOU. JUST A BRIEF FOLLOW
UP. UH, TO THAT, UM, WE'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT INTRAMURAL SPORTS
WHEN WE WERE TALKING ABOUT THIS
ISSUE, UM, AND THAT'S WHY IT'S A
DIFFICULT ISSUE. WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT PEOPLE KIDS THAT ARE
COMPETING FOR SCHOLARSHIPS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GO TO COLLEGE AND
HAVE THAT PAID FOR, AND UM AND
INTRAMURAL SPORTS HAVE BEEN
AROUND FOREVER. I PLAYED
INTRAMURAL SPORTS BECAUSE YOU
I'M ONE OF THOSE THAT WAS A
LITTLE SMALL TO BE PLAYING ON
THE FOOTBALL TEAM. AND I KNOW
SENATOR. MY GOOD. THE GOOD
SENATOR FROM GINA. UH, WOULD
PROBABLY, UH, FIND THAT
SURPRISING, BUT ANYWAY, UM WHEN
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT KIDS THAT ARE IN
CO ARE IN HIGH SCHOOL OR COLLEGE
PLAYING COMPETITIVELY. AND THAT
COMPETITIVENESS IS WHAT'S GOING
TO GET THEM INTO COLLEGE. AND IF
THEY ARE NOT ALLOWED TO PLAY, MY
DAUGHTER PLAYED TENNIS. IF SHE
WAS PLAYING AGAINST A BIOLOGICAL
MALE, SHE WOULD NOT HAVE PLAYED
TENNIS AND SHE GOT SO MUCH FROM
JUST BEING ON ONE OF THE BEST
TENNIS TEAMS IN THE STATE. THIS
IS NOT AN ATTACK ON NOT ALLOWING
TRANS KIDS OR ANY OTHER KIDS TO
PLAY WITH PEOPLE OF THE OPPOSITE
SEX. WE'VE BEEN DOING THAT
FOREVER. IT'S ABOUT COMPETITIVE
SPORTS. THAT'S WHAT IT'S ABOUT.
WE WISH NÓ HARM TO ANYBODY. THE
FOLKS THAT ARE ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT THIS ISSUE WITH OUR
FEMALES IN SPORTS AND MALES IN
SPORTS. IT'S WE JUST WE THE
WOMEN FOUGHT FOUGHT SO HARD. SO
HARD. TO GET THE RIGHTS. THE
TITLE IX TO BE ABLE TO COMPETE
AND MAKE MONEY LIKE THE GUYS ARE
DOING. THEY FINALLY GOT THERE.
AND NOW WE HAVE THIS ISSUE THAT
IS CHALLENGING SOME OF THAT AND
WE HAVE TO COME TO GRIPS WITH
THAT. AND IF WE'RE GOING TO PUT
A CONTROVERSIAL ISSUE LIKE THAT
INTO A GREAT RESOLUTION,
OTHERWISE THAT IT MAKES IT
NONSUPPORT THAT MAYBE WE SHOULD
BE LOOKING AT THAT ONE THING AND
SAYING, HEY, YOU KNOW WHAT?
MAYBE THIS SHOULDN'T BE IN HERE.
SO UH, I WILL BE JOINING MY
COLLEAGUES AND, UH, VOTING NÓ ON
BEHALF OF ALL THE YOUNG LADIES
THAT ARE COMPETING, LIKE HECK.
TO EXCEL IN SPORTS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, SENATOR EGGMAN. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, MR PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS I RISE AS THE CHAIR OF
THE L GB Tð Q CAUCUS. UH, WE
SPEND A LOT OF TIME TALKING
ABOUT WHAT THIS RESOLUTION IS
NOT, UH, I WANNA REMIND
EVERYBODY. THIS IS THE DAY OF
TRANSVISION WHAT WE'RE SAYING TO
OUR TRANS BROTHERS AND SISTERS.
WE SEE YOU. YOU BELONG HERE. WE
WELCOME YOU HERE. UH AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. ALL RIGHT, I'LL DEBATE
HAVING èC SENATOR ATKINS, YOU
MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT, COLLEAGUES. THANK YOU
. CLEARLY DISCUSSION WILL
CONTINUE ON A NUMBER OF THESE
ISSUES IN SOCIETY, WHICH IS EVEN
MORE THE REASON WE NEED TO STAND
AND SUPPORT A VISIBILITY AND THE
RIGHT TO BE WHO WE ARE. I WOULD
POINT OUT. UH, GOSH, I WAS A
KID. BILLIE JEAN KING ACTUALLY
WON THAT TENNIS MATCH THAT HAS
RESONATED FOR DECADES. STILL UM
AND SHE WAS HONORED BY THE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS. OR THE GÂY
CAUCUS. I MAY BE BOTH CAUCUSES
I. I CAN'T REMEMBER AT THIS
POINT AND LET'S TALK ABOUT
CAITLIN CLARK. AND THEN I'M
GONNA GET OFF THE SPORTS. UH
ANALOGIES BECAUSE I THINK THAT
AS WE SEE SOCIETY CHANGE. WE
RISE TO THE OCCASION IN
DIFFERENT WAYS. AND WE BECOME
THE VERY BEST THAT WE CAN.
WHOEVER WE ARE, IN WHATEVER WAY
WE DO WHAT WE ENJOY DOING IN
LIFE, AND THAT INCLUDES SPORTS.
BUT I WANTED TO LIKE MY
COLLEAGUE FROM STOCKTON. BRING
IT BACK TO, UH, REALLY THE POINT
OF THE BROADER RESOLUTION IS
ABOUT SUPPORT. UH AND VISIBILITY
FOR A COMMUNITY THAT HAS MADE
GREAT STRIDES OVER OVER THESE
LAST SEVERAL DECADES, AND YET
RIGHT NOW, BECAUSE OF THOSE
STRIDES AND THE ABILITY TO HAVE
SOME, UM, EQUALITY AND SOME
SUCCESS IN IN GAINING RIGHTS
THERE IS A BACKLASH. WHICH IS
WHY WE END UP HAVING THE DAY OF
REMEMBRANCE WHERE WE PAY TRIBUTE
TO THOSE WHO'VE DIED, AND
TYPICALLY, AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM
GARDENA SAYS THEY'RE TYPICALLY
PEOPLE OF COLOR. UH, THAT ARE
MORE TARGETED. UM YOU KNOW WHAT?
YOU'VE HEARD ME SAY ON THE
FLOOR. YOU KNOW, I GREW UP IN
SOUTHWEST VIRGINIA IN A VERY
CONSERVATIVE COMMUNITY, A VERY
CHURCH GOING COMMUNITY. MY MOM
WAS A PART OF THAT. AND WHEN I
WAS A KID, AND AT AGE, 17
REALIZED THAT I WAS A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT. THERE WERE NÓ ROLE
MODELS AROUND ME. I WAS THINKING
ABOUT THIS RESOLUTION LAST NIGHT
AND STANDING ON THE FLOOR AND
ANTICIPATING THIS DIALOGUE, AND
IT OCCURRED TO ME I WAS WRONG. I
ACTUALLY DID HAVE AN EXAMPLE
THAT I RAN INTO ONE DAY. MY
SISTER AND I WHEN WE WERE 1011
YEARS OLD, USED TO PASS HER ON
THE STREET IN OUR NEIGHBORHOOD
AND COMMUNITY, SHE WOULD BE
GOING HOME FROM THE NIGHT SHIFT
AT WORK. AND I SAY SHE BECAUSE
THAT'S HOW SHE PRESENTED. AND,
UM YOU KNOW, AT THAT TIME MY
SISTER AND I FINALLY REALIZED
THERE WAS SOMETHING A LITTLE
DIFFERENT ABOUT HER. AND TODAY
WHAT I WOULD SAY AND WHAT WE
REALIZED IS THAT SHE WAS LIKELY
TRANSGENDER. 50 YEARS AGO. WHAT
COURAGE THAT MUST HAVE TAKEN AND
IT BORE OUT. IT WAS TRUE. I
REMEMBER TALKING TO MY MOTHER
AND MY MOTHER WHO WILL ALWAYS BE
THE ROLE MODEL OF ACCEPTANCE AND
KINDNESS. NEXT TO DOLLY PARTON.
MY MOTHER. WHO SAID TO ME IN HER
? I MEAN, SHE WAS PENTECOSTAL
HOLINESS TILL THE DAY SHE LEFT
US. AND SHE SAID TO MY SISTER
AND I, YOU BE KIND SHE IS
DIFFERENT. AND GOD LOVES ALL OF
HIS CHILDREN. AND I NEVER FORGOT
THAT BECAUSE FOR ME IT IT REALLY
SET THE TONE IN MY LIFE. AND SO
WHEN I CAME OUT TO MY MOTHER
ACCEPTANCE WAS AS SHE REALLY
DIDN'T UNDERSTAND MUCH LIKE MY
COLLEAGUE, UH, FROM SANTA CRUZ
WAS EXPLAINING WHAT WE'VE HAD TO
LEARN OVER THE LAST 2030 40
YEARS. UH, HOW LANGUAGE AND
CULTURE CHANGE AND HOW WE HAVE
TO, UH, MAYBE RECOGNIZE AND
ADJUST THAT THAT WE'RE A LITTLE
WE'RE A LITTLE BEHIND.
OCCASIONALLY MY MOTHER NEVER WAS
NOT IN THE AREA OF KINDNESS, NOT
IN THE AREA OF ACCEPTANCE. AND
SO TODAY, YOU KNOW WHEN I STAND
UP I, UM, HAVE HAD TO LEARN SO
MUCH. IN THE LAST COUPLE OF
DECADES, BUT I STAND HERE
STRONGLY SUPPORTIVE OF THIS
RESOLUTION AND THE FACT THAT WE
SHOULD BE SUPPORTING VERBALLY TO
COUNTER ALL THAT'S GOING ON
ACROSS THIS COUNTRY. FOR THOSE
WHO HAVE BEEN BRAVE ENOUGH TO
TELL US WHO THEY ARE AND TO MAKE
THOSE TRANSITIONS DESPITE
EVERYTHING AGAINST THEM, AND SO
I URGE YOU, UH, I KNOW DIALOGUE
WILL CONTINUE. I JUST HOPE IN
THE IN THE WAY OF HOW WE EDUCATE
EACH OTHER THAT THAT'S WHAT WE
AWAY FROM THIS TODAY, UM, THAT
MANY OF US HAVE A LOT TO LEARN,
OBVIOUSLY IN EVERY DIRECTION.
AND SO I THINK MY COLLEAGUES FOR
THEIR CONVERSATION. I STILL
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR S¼ R 70 TODAY.
SENATOR ATKINS HAS CLOSED THE
DEBATE. SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALUN. AYE, A GIO. HIY
ARCHULETA, HØI ASHBY, IY ATKINS.
HIY BECKER. AYE, BLAKESPEAR.
AYE, BRADFORD. CABALLERO.
CORTEZ. IY DELHI. NÓ AYE, DURAZO
. I EG I GLAZER I. I GONZALEZ
HØI GROVE. NÓ HURTADO. ALL
RIGHT, JONES. LAD. ED. I LEMON.
UH, MCGUIRE. UH, MENJIVAR. ALL
RIGHT, MEN. HØI NEWMAN. HØI.
AYE. WHEN NÓ NILO. OR BY THE UH,
PORTANTINO. AYE, ROTH. AYE,
RUBIO. AYE, SEYARTO. NÓ SKINNER.
AYE, CUEVAS. AYE, STERN. UH,
UMBERG? AYE, WAHAB. UH, WIENER.
AYE, WILK. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. JONES. NÓ NILO.
TRIAL. WELL. ON A VOTE OF 32 TO
5. THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED
MEMBERS. WE'RE GONNA MOVE NEXT
TO FILE ITEM 13, FOLLOWED BY
FILE ITEM 14 AND 21. FILE ITEM
13 IS S¼ èC R 121 BY SENATOR
WAHAB SECRETARY. PLEASE READ
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION 121
BY SENATOR WAHAB RELATIVE TO
INTERNATIONAL WOMEN'S DAY,
SENATOR, THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU. I RISE TO PRESENT S¼
èC R 121 INTERNATIONAL WOMEN'S
DAY INTERNATIONAL WOMEN'S DAY IS
A CELEBRATION OF THE
ACHIEVEMENTS OF WOMEN WHILE
CONTINUING TO CALL FOR GENDER
PARITY AND EQUITY. INTERNATIONAL
WOMEN'S DAY GIVES US A CHANCE TO
LOOK BACK ON OUR SUCCESSES AND
RECOMMIT TO THE WORK THAT STILL
NEEDS TO BE DONE. I RECENTLY
CELEBRATED INTERNATIONAL WOMEN'S
DAY BY HONORING WOMEN IN MY
DISTRICT. THESE ARE WOMEN WHO
ARE INVOLVED AND ENGAGED IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES WHO ARE FILLED
WITH KINDNESS AND COMPASSION WHO
GIVE FORWARD BY MODELING FOR
YOUNGER GENERATIONS WHAT IT
MEANS TO GIVE BACK WHO SPEAK UP
AND SPEAK OUT WHEN THE VOICES OF
OTHERS GO UNHEARD. WHO SHOW
OTHERS ALL THE WAYS IN WHICH
THEY CAN USE THEIR OWN VOICES TO
EFFECT CHANGE. WHO CREATES
SPACES BUILT AROUND UPLIFTING
OTHER WOMEN WHO ADVOCATE FOR
CIVIL RIGHTS FOR ALL AND WHO
NEVER SHY AWAY FROM STANDING IN
THEIR OWN POWER. AS WOMEN
LEADERS AND CHANGE MAKERS, WHILE
WE STILL HAVE A LONG WAY TO GO
TO ACHIEVE GENDER PARITY AND
EQUITY, I AM HUMBLED BY THE
WOMEN IN MY DISTRICT. AND IN
THIS CHAMBER AND AROUND THE
WORLD WHO DEMONSTRATE THAT WOMEN
HAVE BEEN LEADERS CAPABLE OF
CHANGING THE WORLD. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN EYE
VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION ON THIS
RESOLUTION? ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION. IT IS ELIGIBLE. OH,
EXCUSE ME, SENATOR SKINNER.
THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS.
I ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT OF S¼ èC
R 121 THANK THE AUTHOR AND I
WILL NOTE THAT, UH, IT IS
LOOKING HIGHLY LIKELY THAT, UH,
AFTER NOVEMBER'S ELECTION, THIS
HOUSE WILL HAVE PARITY, GENDER
PARITY. THANK YOU, SENATOR
SKINNER ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
ON THIS RESOLUTION? THE NON
CENTER W, YOU MAY CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I VOTE
MEMBERS. THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. THAT
OBJECTION. EYES 40 NÓ ZERO, THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM
14 BY SENATOR ALLEN, THIS IS S¼
èC R 120 THREE, SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ SENATE AND CURRENT
RESOLUTION 120 THREE BY SENATOR
ALLEN RELATIVE TO OURS.
EDUCATION MONTH, SENATOR ALLEN.
WELL THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT.
OBVIOUSLY WE LEARNED ABOUT OUR
WONDERFUL POETRY OUT LOUD, YOUNG
PEOPLE. UH UH, EARLIER AND
THAT'S WHY THIS IS A AAA
WONDERFUL SEGUE. UH, WE'RE WE'RE
PRESENTING S¼ èC R 12 THREE,
WHICH DECLARES MARCH 2024 AS
ARTS EDUCATION MONTH. UH, WE
KNOW THAT ARTS EDUCATION IS A
KEYSTONE ELEMENT OF OUR
CURRICULA, FOSTERING YOUNG
CALIFORNIANS CREATIVITY.
CRITICAL THINKING SKILLS AND
LANGUAGE MASTERY STUDENTS WITH
ACCESS TO ROBUST ARTS EDUCATION
PROGRAMS BENEFIT ACROSS, UH,
EXPERIENCE BENEFITS ACROSS THE
BOARD FROM INCREASED ACADEMIC
PERFORMANCE TO ELEVATED, UH,
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT AND ONE OF
THE KIND OF SAD BUT VERY
IMPORTANT TRUTH IS THAT THAT AN
ARTS EDUCATION CAN OFTENTIMES BE
THE KEY DIFFERENTIATOR FOR KIDS
THAT MIGHT OTHERWISE BE AT RISK
OR OR AT RISK OF DROPPING OUT?
THERE'S SOMETHING ABOUT AN ARTS
CURRICULUM THAT CONNECTS TO A
LOT OF THOSE KIDS THAT, UH, MAY
NOT BE YOU KNOW, EASILY
CONNECTED TO THE TRADITIONAL
CURRICULUM. UH, SO BY EQUIPPING
YOUNG PEOPLE WITH THE TOOLS FOR
SELF YOU KNOW, CONFIDENT SELF
EXPRESSION AND A DIVERSE SET OF
MEDIA THROUGH WHICH TO EXPLORE
IDEAS IN HUMAN STORIES. WE CAN
ACCELERATE THEIR ACADEMIC AND
SOCIAL DEVELOPMENT AND OPEN
COUNTLESS DOORS FOR THEIR
FUTURES THAT WE KNOW THE ART
SERVES AS A UNIFYING FORCE
CONNECTING ALL THOSE WHO
PARTICIPATE TO A SHARED
TRADITION AND COLLECTIVE
EXPERIENCE, REGARDLESS OF AGE,
BACKGROUND AND OR ANY OTHER
FACTOR, AS THE NEXT GENERATION
TAKES LEADERSHIP OF OUR
INDUSTRIES AND SOCIETAL
CONVERSATIONS IN AN AREA AREA OF
GA. I HUMAN CREATIVITY WILL BE
MORE VITAL THAN EVER IN GETTING
THE USE OF BRIDGING TECHNOLOGIES
IN THE ARTS AND FOR A PERFECT
REPRESENTATION OF THE VALUE OF
ARTS EDUCATION. LOOK NÓ FURTHER
THAN THE TALENTED STUDENTS THAT
WE, UH, TALKED ABOUT EARLIER.
UH, TODAY PROGRAMS LIKE POETRY
OUT LOUD. AND SO MANY OTHERS
THAT WE KNOW EXIST ACROSS OUR
ARTS CURRICULUM AND OUR IN OUR
SCHOOLS HAVE HAVE IMMEASURABLE
LIFELONG IMPACT FOR
PARTICIPATING STUDENTS AND
DESERVE TO BE A PART OF EVERY
CALIFORNIANS EDUCATION. AS VICE
CHAIR OF OUR LEGISLATORS,
LEGISLATURES JOINT COMMITTEE ON
THE ARTS. I'M I'M VERY PROUD TO
EMPHASIZE THE INCALCULABLE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF THE ARTS ON
CALIFORNIA'S POSITION AS A NEXUS
OF CULTURE, INNOVATION AND
ECONOMIC PROSPERITY. IT'S ALSO
INCUMBENT UPON US TO AS A
LEGISLATURE TO CONTINUE
SUPPORTING PROGRAMS TO ENSURE
THAT STUDENTS LIKE RILEY AND
MIRA AND CæA, WHO WE HONORED
THIS MORNING, CONTINUE TO HAVE
WORLD CLASS OPPORTUNITIES ACROSS
THE STATE. AND IT'S IN THAT
SPIRIT THAT I ASK YOU TO, UH,
ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE ON S¼ èC R
123. THANK YOU, SENATOR ALLEN,
SENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
OF THE SENATE, I ALSO RISE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF S¼ èC R 123
RECOGNIZING THE MONTH OF MARCH
AS ARTS EDUCATION MONTH, UH, AS
A MEMBER OF THE JOINT COMMITTEE
ON THE ARTS, ALSO AS A MEMBER OF
THE CALIFORNIA CREATIVE ECONOMY
WORKING GROUP TO EXPAND THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES IN THE CREATIVE
SECTOR HERE IN CALIFORNIA, UM I
WANNA ALSO PIGGYBACK ON THE
AUTHOR'S COMMENTS IN TERMS OF
WHAT IT MEANS TO SOME OF OUR
STUDENTS IN THE CLASSROOM,
ESPECIALLY, UH, IN OUR INNER
CITY COMMUNITIES WHERE ARTS
GIVES THE OPPORTUNITY FOR OUR
STUDENTS TO EXPRESS SO MANY WITH
SO MANY ISSUES, AND THEY DON'T
HAVE A CREATIVE OUTLET, TOO, TO
LET SOME OF THOSE EMOTIONS OUT
OR WHAT THEY'RE FEELING AND MANY
TO THE ARTS, OR THEY DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO THE ARTS. THEY'LL
CHOOSE GANGS, AND SO I KNOW HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS IN OUR
CLASSROOMS. LAST YEAR, I WORKED
TIRELESSLY TO BRING FUNDING INTO
OUR CLASSROOMS AND OUR
COMMUNITIES BECAUSE I BELIEVE
THAT IN YEARS PAST, THE ARTS
USED TO BE FOR THOSE THAT ARE
PRIVILEGED WITH FUNDING WITH THE
PARENTS, AND IT SHOULDN'T BE
THAT WAY. EVERY CHILD IN
CALIFORNIA SHOULD HAVE ACCESS TO
THE ARTS, BE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE
AND BE ABLE TO HAVE ACCESS TO IN
THE CLASSROOMS. AS THE AUTHOR
STATED, UH, ARTS, EDUCATION
FURTHERS ACADEMIC GOALS, AND I
KNOW THAT FIRST HAND AS A 20
YEAR TEACHER VETERAN AND I KNOW
THAT I DID THAT, AND I
INCORPORATED THE ARTS IN OUR
CLASSROOMS. BUT IT WASN'T ALWAYS
PART OF THE CURRICULUM. AND I
KNOW WHAT IT DID TO OUR
STUDENTS. UH, THEY BECOME A
BETTER HUMANS, WELL ROUNDED
STUDENTS THEY ARE ABLE TO
EXPRESS THEMSELVES ARE ABLE TO,
UH, FEEL CONFIDENT. IT JUST
BRINGS SO MANY, UH,
OPPORTUNITIES AND VALUE TO THE
OUR LITTLE HUMAN BEINGS, AND I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
CONTINUE TO PUSH THE ARTS IN OUR
CLASSROOMS. EVERY STUDENT HAS A
RIGHT TO GROW UP IN A WELL
ROUNDED SITUATION AND INCLUDES
THE BENEFITS THAT THE ARTS
BRINGS. UH THESE BENEFITS
INCLUDE EVERYTHING FROM PROBLEM
SOLVING BEING BETTER
COMMUNICATORS, UH, BEING TEAM
PLAYERS IN A IN A IN AN ARTS
PERFORMANCE, AND SO WITH THAT I
ALSO WHOLEHEARTEDLY STRONGLY
SUPPORT. UH, S¼ èC R 120 THREE.
THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT. THANK
YOU, SENATOR RUBIO ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION ON THE RESOLUTION FOR
THE DISCUSSION? SEEN NÓ SENATOR
ALLEN MAY CLOSE. I REALLY
APPRECIATE MY COLLEAGUE'S
COMMENTS. I APPRECIATE THE LONG
STANDING SUPPORT, UH, FOR THIS
ISSUE OF THIS BODY AND I HAVE
RESPECT FOR US AND I VOTE
MEMBERS. THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. NÓ
OBJECTIONS. AYES 40 NÓ ZERO ON
THE RESOLUTION. RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. WE'RE GONNA MOVE NEXT
TO ASSEMBLY. THIRD READING. THIS
IS P ITEM, 21. SECRETARY. PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY CURRENT RESOLUTION
86 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARA
RELATIVE TO ANIMALS. SENATOR MON
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
PRESIDENT I'M NOT CELEBRATING
ANYBODY'S WEEK OR YEAR OR
ANYTHING. I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
ANIMALS AND OUR OVERPOPULATION
IN OUR POUNDS. UM JUST THIS LAST
WEEK IN, UH, THE DISTRICT I
SHARE WITH SENATOR ALVARADO GILL
. THERE WAS A CASE OF, UH UH,
SOMEBODY WITH A MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUE WITH HOARDING HAD ALMOST
42 HOURS LIVING IN ONE HOUSE AND
THAT SAME UH, CITY. THERE WAS A
TRUCK THAT WAS CONFISCATED. THEY
WERE BREEDING DOGS AND OVER 30
MORE DOGS THAT FOUND US LIVING
IN A VAN. THE STREETS. SO WE
HAVE A HUGE PROBLEM WHICH CAUSES
OUR POUNDS TO BE OVERRUN. UH, SO
ONE OF THE OPTIONS THAT WE
SHOULD WE'RE REALLY WORK ON IS
SPAYING AND NEUTERING. THAT'S
RIGHT. FRIENDS SPAYING AND
NEUTERING, AND WE UNDERSTAND
THIS IS A HUGE ISSUE EXASPERATED
BY OUR LACK OF, UH UH,
VETERINARIANS, BUT WE REALLY
NEED TO WORK AT EVERY ISSUE. WE
CAN LOCAL NONPROFITS ARE POUNDS,
EVERYBODY ELSE TO BRING
AWARENESS AND PROGRAMS NEXT TIME
THERE'S EXTRA MONEY IN THE
BUDGET TO BE ABLE TO HELP OUR
COMMUNITIES. LET'S ALL THINK
ABOUT SETTING UP PROGRAMS FOR
SPAYING AND NEUTERING. UH AND
ESPECIALLY IN AREAS THAT HAVE
HIGHER DEGREES OF POVERTY. UM WE
KNOW THAT THE OVERPOPULATION OF
PETS TENDS TO BE EVEN HIGHER. SO
UH, AS WE GO ABOUT OUR TIME,
LET'S THINK ABOUT A èC R 86
WHERE WE REALLY ENCOURAGING
EVERY LEVEL TO WORK TOGETHER TO
SPAY AND NEUTER OUR PETS TO CUT
DOWN ON THE OVERPOPULATION. A
POUND OF ANIMALS IN OUR POUNDS I
ASKED FOR YOUR I VOTE. THANK
YOU, SENATOR MON ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION. ON THE RESOLUTION
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION? SEE NOW
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. THAT OBJECTION. I 400
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA NOW MOVE
BACK TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS.
THIS IS THE TIME TO ADDRESS
ADJOURN IN MEMORY. MEMBERS OF
THE SENATE. WANT TO ASK EVERYONE
TO PLEASE GIVE US SPEAKER. YOUR
ATTENTION ON A JOURNEY. MEMORIES
FIRST UP, WE'LL RECOGNIZE
SENATOR ATKINS. SENATOR ATKINS.
THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES I RISE TODAY TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF CANDACE
CARROLL, A TRAILBLAZER FOR WOMEN
IN THE LEGAL FIELD IN SAN DIEGO,
WHO PASSED AWAY LAST MONTH AT
THE AGE OF 79. CANDACE CAME FROM
A HUMBLE BACKGROUND. SHE WAS
BORN IN OHIO, BUT SPENT MOST OF
HER CHILDHOOD IN WASHINGTON, Dð
èC, SHE WORKED TO PUT HERSELF
THROUGH COLLEGE AT GEORGE
WASHINGTON UNIVERSITY, AND LATER
SHE RECEIVED A FULL RIDE
SCHOLARSHIP TO DUKE LAW SCHOOL.
WHILE ATTENDING LAW SCHOOL, SHE
MET LYNN SIMON, HER HUSBAND OF
NEARLY 50 YEARS. TOGETHER, THEY
HAD THREE CHILDREN. IN ADDITION
TO BEING A WIFE AND A MOTHER,
CANDACE WORKED HARD TO ESTABLISH
HER LEGAL CAREER AND WHAT WAS A
VERY MALE DOMINATED FIELD AT THE
TIME. AFTER GRADUATING LAW
SCHOOL IN 1974, SHE COMPLETED A
CLERKSHIP WITH THE U S¼ COURT OF
APPEALS Dð èC CIRCUIT AND THEN
BEGAN WORKING AS AN APPELLANT,
ATTORNEY FOR THE NATIONAL LABOR
RELATIONS BOARD. WHEN SHE MOVED
WITH HER FAMILY TO SAN DIEGO IN
1983, SHE JOINED THE LAW FIRM
NOW KNOWN AS SULLIVAN HILL AND
REMAINED WITH THAT FIRM FOR THE
REST OF HER LIFE. SHE'S
REMEMBERED BY U S¼ DISTRICT
JUDGE BARRY TED MOSKOWITZ, WHO
SERVED AS CHIEF FEDERAL JUDGE IN
SAN DIEGO FOR SEVEN YEARS AS A
GIANT IN OUR LEGAL COMMUNITY,
WHO OVERCAME A MALE DOMINATED
BAR AND BECAME A PARTNER IN A
WELL REGARDED LAW FIRM. SHE WAS
AN ADVOCATE FOR WOMEN IN THE
LEGAL PROFESSION, PARTICULARLY
FOR YOUNG WOMEN JUGGLING
MOTHERHOOD, ALONG WITH A
DEMANDING CAREER. SHE WAS DEEPLY
COMMITTED TO EQUALITY AND
FAIRNESS FOR ALL PEOPLE. SHE WAS
ESPECIALLY SUPPORTIVE OF WOMEN
OF THE L GB Tð. Q PLUS COMMUNITY
WORKERS, IMMIGRANTS, REFUGEES
AND ANYONE ELSE SHE FELT WAS
DISADVANTAGED OR BEING TREATED
UNFAIRLY. CANDACE PUT HER
BELIEFS INTO ACTION BY
VOLUNTEERING HER TIME IN MANY
ORGANIZATIONS, BOTH STATEWIDE
AND LOCAL TO SAN DIEGO. SHE
SERVED AS PRESIDENT OF THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY BAR ASSOCIATION IN
1998, PRESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA
WOMEN LAWYERS IN 2000 THREE AND
2004, AND SHE WAS CHAIRWOMAN OF
SENATOR BARBARA BOXER SAN DIEGO
ADVISORY COMMITTEE FOR FEDERAL
JUDGE AND U S¼ ATTORNEY
NOMINATIONS SHE SERVED ON BOARDS
OF THE AMERICAN CIVIL LIBERTIES
UNION, THE SAN DIEGO OPERA, THE
CHAPTER OF THE INTERNATIONAL
RESCUE COMMITTEE, THE SAN DIEGO
CONVENTION CENTER AND THE SAN
DIEGO VOLUNTEER LAWYERS PROGRAM.
HER DEDICATION TO FIGHTING FOR
THOSE LESS FORTUNATE TO HER
COMMUNITY AND TO HER FAMILY WAS
INSPIRATIONAL, AND SHE
ACCOMPLISHED A GREAT DEAL IN HER
79 YEARS OF LIFE ON A MORE
PERSONAL NOTE, UH, I THINK
YOU'VE HEARD ME SAY BEFORE, WHEN
WE'VE LOST INCREDIBLE CIVIC
LEADERS FROM SAN DIEGO THAT, UM
SHE? THERE ARE THOSE WHEN WE RUN
FOR OFFICE OR ASPIRE TO
LEADERSHIP, UH, THAT ARE A RIGHT
OF PASSAGE. YOU HAVE TO GO TALK
TO THEM BEFORE YOU DECIDE TO
MOVE FORWARD IN 1993 94. MY
PREDECESSOR, CHRISTINE KEHOE,
RAN FOR CITY COUNCIL. SHE SHE
HAD TO TAKE A FEW MINUTES AND
MEET WITH CANDACE CARROLL IN
1999 2000. WHEN I RAN FOR CITY
COUNCIL, SHE WAS ONE OF THOSE
CIVIC LEADERS THAT I HAD TO MEET
WITH. AND IF YOU WANTED THE
SUPPORT, UM YOU KNOW AGAIN, IT
WAS REALLY A RITE OF PASSAGE.
AND WHY IS IT THAT THOSE WILL
ALWAYS HAVE PIERCING EYES AND
CAN LOOK RIGHT INTO YOUR VERY
SOUL TO DETERMINE IF YOU'RE THE
REAL DEAL OR NOT, THAT WAS
CANDACE. SHE SURVIVED BY HER
HUSBAND, LYNN, THEIR SONS,
DANIEL, MATTHEW AND DAVID. HER
SISTER, GLOVER, CAROL, AND MANY
IN-LAWS, NIECES, NEPHEWS,
GRANDNIECES AND NEPHEWS AND,
FRANKLY, A HUGE COMMUNITY OF
PEOPLE THAT ADORED HER
COLLEAGUES. I ASK THAT WE
ADJOURN TODAY IN MEMORY OF
CANDACE CARROLL, A HUMANITARIAN,
A BRILLIANT LEGAL MIND A TRUE
FEMINIST WHO LEFT AN ADMIRABLE
LEGACY ON SAN DIEGO AND THE
LEGAL PROFESSION. THANK YOU,
SENATOR ATKINS. THE SENATE
EXTENDS OUR CONDOLENCES TO HER
MANY FRIENDS AND FAMILY. PLEASE
BRING HER NAME FORWARD SO SHE
CAN BE PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED IN
THE SENATE JOURNAL AS WE ADJOURN
IN HER MEMORY. NEXT UP, SENATOR
ARTETA. THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT.
IRONIC. TODAY WE'RE HONORING
WOMEN. WE HAVE WOMEN HEROES IN
OUR AND OUR HOME. CITIES AND
COUNTIES THAT WE DON'T EVEN KNOW
ABOUT. SOME OF THEM ARE PART OF
THE GREATEST GENERATION AND I
HAVE ONE TO SHARE WITH YOU
TODAY. MR PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS
I RISE TODAY TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF MARGE VIA A TRAIL
BLAZING FEMALE BASEBALL STAR
FROM MONTEBELLO IN MY DISTRICT,
BORN DECEMBER 21ST 1924 MARGE
PLAYED SPORTS FROM A YOUNG AGE
GROWING UP IN MONTEBELLO. WHICH
AT THE TIME WAS LARGELY A
MEXICAN AMERICAN FARMING
COMMUNITY. MARGE BEGAN PLAYING
SPORTS PROFESSIONALLY. LISTEN TO
THIS. AT THE YOUNG AGE OF 13,
SHE SNUCK IN. GOT A FEW DOLLARS
BROUGHT IT HOME BECAUSE SHE
PLAYED FOR A TEAM CALLED THE
ORANGE COUNTY LIONES FAST PITCH
SOFTBALL AND SHE WAS BEING PAID
FOR IT. MARGE ATTENDED
MONTEBELLO HIGH SCHOOL DURING
THIS TIME AS WELL BUT ULTIMATELY
QUIT SCHOOL TO WORK IN THE
UNITED STATES RUBBER PLANT TO
SUPPORT THE WAR EFFORT. IN 1946,
MARGE JOINED THE ALL AMERICAN
GIRLS. BASEBALL LEAGUE FEATURED
IN A LEAGUE OF THEIR OWN AS A
MEMBER OF THE CONES, COMMENTS.
MARGE WAS ONE OF 39 PLAYERS BORN
IN CALIFORNIA TO JOIN THE LEAGUE
IN ITS 12 YEAR HISTORY AND
PLAYED CATCHER, SECOND BASE AND
SHORTSTOP. ADDITIONALLY SHE WAS
ONE OF 11 LATINAS AND ONE OF
ONLY TWO AMERICAN LATINAS THAT
PLAYED IN THE ALL AMERICAN GIRLS
PROFESSIONAL BASEBALL LEAGUE.
ABOUT THAT. ON JUNE 9TH 1946
MARGE MADE HISTORY WHEN SHE
DROVE IN NINE RUNS, COLLECTED 11
TOTAL BASES IN THE CONTEST,
SETTING TWO SINGLE GAME LEAGUE
RECORDS THAT WOULD NEVER BE
SURPASSED OR BROKEN. MARGE WAS
ALSO HONORED AS PART OF A
PERMANENT DISPLAY TITLED WOMEN
IN BASEBALL IN THE BASEBALL HALL
OF FAME AND THE MUSEUM IN
COOPERSTOWN IN NEW YORK. MARGE
MARRIED DANIEL. UH, CRAYON.
DURING THE 19 FIFTIES, MOVING TO
WHITTIER AND LATER TO LÀ MARATA
BEFORE RETURNING TO MONTEBELLO.
HER HUSBAND, CRAYON PASSED IN
DECEMBER OF 2020 AFTER BASEBALL
MARCH, TOOK UP GOLF AND WON
NUMEROUS TOURNAMENTS AT THE
HACIENDA GOLF CLUB IN LÀ HABRA
HEIGHTS HERE IN CALIFORNIA, IN
ADDITION TO HER TALENT ON THE
FIELD, MARGS COMMITMENT TO HER
COMMUNITY, HER HERITAGE AND HER
IDENTITY IS AN INSPIRATION TO
ALL YOUNG WOMEN WHO ASPIRE TO
PLAY. HER LEGACY EXTENDS BEYOND
THE BASEBALL CAREER. MARCH
LASTING IMPACT IS A FEARLESS AND
HER DEDICATION TO UPLIFTING
OTHERS WHETHER THEY TOOK THE
FORM OF BLAZING A TRAIL FOR
FUTURE LATINO ATHLETES.
MENTORING YOUNG PLAYERS OR
PUSHING FOR FAIRNESS AND
EQUALITY IN SPORTS. MARGE IS
ALWAYS THERE TO HELP YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO SHARED HER PASSION
FOR ATHLETICS IN HONOR OF HER
CONTRIBUTIONS TO SPORTS AND THE
MONTEBELLO COMMUNITY. MONTEBELLO
NEED THE CITY'S YOUTH SOFTBALL
LEAGUE STADIUM. MARGE VILLA
FIELD IN 2021. I HAD THE HONOR
TO MEET HER ENTIRE FAMILY, AS
WELL AS ALL OF US, WHO APPLAUDED
HER DEDICATION AND PASSION FOR
HER COMMUNITY AND CHILDREN. WERE
MARGIN SURVIVED BY HER SON,
JOHN. MY DAUGHTER RENEE, HER
GRANDSON, JOSH, DALLAS DREW AND
HER GREAT GRANDSON, COLE. FOR
THESE REASONS, I ASKED ADJOURN
IN HER MEMORY. MARGE VIA THANK
YOU, MR PRESIDENT. THE SENATE
EXTENDS ITS CONDOLENCES TO THE
MANY FRIENDS AND FAMILY IN THIS
VILLA. PLEASE BRING HER NAME
FORWARD SO SHE COULD BE PROPER
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED IN THE
SENATE JOURNAL SENATOR ARCHULETA
SO WE MAY ADJOURN IN HER MEMORY.
NEXT STEP. WE WANNA RECOGNIZE
SENATOR UMBERG. UH THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT, COLLEAGUES, I RISE TO
HONOR THE LIFE AND MEMORY OF
JUDGE FRANCISCO PEDRO PHO.
PASSED AWAY AT THE AGE OF 85,
SURROUNDED BY HIS FAMILY AND
LOVED ONES. UH, THE ORANGE
COUNTY REGISTERS HEADLINE WHEN
HE PASSED, SAID HE WAS THE GOLD
STANDARD OF JUDICIAL INTEGRITY.
AND I THINK THAT APTLY DESCRIBES
JUDGE BRISENO PRAISED BY PAUL
MEYER, THAT WAS HIS QUOTE AND IN
PROSECUTORS, UM AND OTHER JUDGES
. HE WAS A BELOVED JUDGE,
COLLEAGUE AND FRIEND OF THE
HISPANIC BAR ASSOCIATION IN THE
ENTIRE BENCH AND BAR. AT AGE 17
JUDGE BRISENO JOINED THE UNITED
STATES MARINE CORPS AFTER SEEING
A POSTER OF A YOUNG MARINE
OFFICER AT EL CAMINO JUNIOR
COLLEGE WITH THE MOTTO YOU, TOO,
CAN BECOME AN OFFICER. IF YOU
HAVE A DEGREE DESPITE STRUGGLING
FINANCIALLY TO AFFORD COLLEGE
JUDGE BRISENO'S DETERMINATION TO
BECOME AN OFFICER PUSHED HIM TO
FINISH. HE JOINED THE MARINE
MARINE CORPS FOR THE FIRST TIME
SERVING FROM 1957 TO 1961 IN
1961 JUDGE, SNO RECEIVED HIS
BACHELOR'S DEGREE FROM
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY LONG
BEACH, AS WELL AS HIS
COMMISSION. HE THEN BEGAN WHAT
WOULD BECOME A MILITARY CAREER
THAT SPANNED THREE DECADES BY
SERVING A THREE YEAR TOUR AS AN
INFANTRY OFFICER WITH A 2ND AND
9TH MARINES IN THE FIRST OR THE
THIRD MARINES, INCLUDING A 16
MONTH TOUR AT WITH, UM, THE
MARINES IN OKINAWA. HE WAS LATER
ASSIGNED AS PROVOST MARSHAL TO
MARINE AIR STATION AND TUSTIN.
THANKS TO A STATION ASSIGNMENT.
HE WAS GIVEN PERMISSION BY THE
MARINES TO STAY AT ONE
ASSIGNMENT. UM AFTER THE BREAK
OUT OF THE VIETNAM WAR, SO WE
COULD ATTEND NIGHT LAW SCHOOL AT
LOYOLA LAW SCHOOL WITH THE
PROVISION THAT HE HAD ONE
OPPORTUNITY TO PASS THE BAR EXAM
AND THEN WOULD BE SHIPPED TO
VIETNAM. 1964 FRANCISCO BRANO
MARRIED HIS WIFE AND HAD TWO
DAUGHTERS. ONE IN 1965 1 IN
1967. JUDGE BRENO TOOK THE BAR
EXAM IN AUGUST OF 1968 AND WAS
THEN IMMEDIATELY DEPLOYED TO
VIETNAM. HE RECALLED THAT THE
MOST DIFFICULT TIME FOR HIM WAS
NOT GOING TO VIETNAM BUT SAYING
GOODBYE TO HIS DAUGHTERS AND
WIFE WHEN THEY WERE ONE AND
THREE YEARS OLD PRIME TIME WHEN
YOU'RE A YOUNG FATHER, DESPITE
BEING AN INVENTORY OFFICER WITH
SELF DESCRIBED LITTLE MECHANICAL
TRAINING OR BACKGROUND. HE WAS
ASSIGNED TO THE FIRST TANKS TO
SERVE AS èC Ó, COMMANDING
OFFICER OF A COMPANY. THEN THREE
MONTHS HE WAS PROMOTED TO MAJOR
AND SIGNED COMPANY COMMANDER OF
THE HÌ AND S¼ COMPANY FIRST
TANKS, WHERE HE RECEIVED WORD
THAT HE HAD PASSED THE BAR AND
HIS TANK BATTALION. COMMANDING
OFFICERS SWORE HIM IN IN VIETNAM
IN DECEMBER, 1968 HER SERVICE IN
VIETNAM. WE RECEIVED THE BRONZE
STORE STAR AND JOINT
COMMENDATION MEDAL, HE RETURNED
TO ORANGE COUNTY IN 1969 AND
REJOINED THE MARINE RESERVE,
SERVING AS AJ, A G OFFICER WITH
THE FOURTH MARINE AIR WING AT EL
TORO. UPON HIS ADMISSION TO THE
CALIFORNIA BAR. JUDGE BRISENO
BECAME A MEMBER OF THE FIRST
GENERATION OF LATINO LAWYERS IN
ORANGE COUNTY AND SERVED AS AN
ORANGE COUNTY DEPUTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY FOR EIGHT YEARS,
HEADING THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
HOMICIDE UNIT FROM 1975 AND
1977. HE WAS APPOINTED TO SAN TO
SANTA ANA MUNICIPAL COURT BY
GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN 1977 AND
WAS ONE OF THE YOUNGEST LAWYERS
EXCUSE ME YOUNGEST JUDGES IN THE
STATE. AT THAT TIME. HE WAS THEN
ELEVATED TO ORANGE COUNTY
SUPERIOR COURT IN 1979 BY
GOVERNOR BROWN. JUDGE BREZINA
WAS HIGHLY REGARDED FOR TAKING
GREAT CARE TO TREAT OTHERS WITH
RESPECT AND COURTESY, BOTH IN
AND OUT OF THE COURTROOM,
SPENDING HIS OWN TIME, ENERGY
AND RESOURCES TO HAVE A POSITIVE
IMPACT ON YOUNG PEOPLE'S LIVES,
WHETHER PRESIDING IN JUVENILE
COURT OR INVITING BUSLOADS OF
ORANGE COUNTY STUDENTS TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE CELEBRATION
OF LAW DAY HELD ON THE STEPS OF
THE OLD COURTHOUSE. IN 2010
JUDGE RESINA WAS AWARDED THE
ORANGE COUNTY HISPANIC BAR
ASSOCIATION'S LIFETIME
ACHIEVEMENT AWARD IN JANUARY.
2011 JUDGE BRISENO BEGAN HIS
SIXTH SIX YEAR TERM AS A JUDGE.
HAVING THE DISTINCTION OF
SERVING LONGER THAN ANY OTHER
JUDGE IN THE 121 YEAR HISTORY OF
ORANGE COUNTY IN 2014, HE
RETIRED JUDGE B¢O IS PROCEEDED
IN DEPTH, UH BY HIS LOVING WIFE,
MARIA 50. THREE YEARS HAVE
PASSED AWAY IN 2018. HE HAS
SURVIVED BY HIS TWO DAUGHTERS,
LINDA AND DEBORAH, HIS SON IN
LAW PETER AND FIVE GRANDCHILDREN
. SOPHIA CRUZ, DUDLEY, JACOB
FRANCISCO, JEFFREY CARROLL AND
KENDALL TOOMEY. THEY ASKED THAT
WE ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF JUDGE
BRINO. THE SENATE EXTENDS ITS
CONDOLENCES TO THE MANY FRIENDS
AND FAMILY OF JUDGE BRISENO.
PLEASE BRING HIS NAME FORWARD
SENATOR ABERG SO WE CAN BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED IN THE
SENATE JOURNAL AND THAT WE MAY
ADJOURN IN HIS MEMORY. THERE ARE
NÓ OTHER BUSINESS BEFORE THE
SENATE, SENATOR MCGUIRE THE DESK
IS CLEAR. THANK YOU SO MUCH, MR
PRESIDENT. GREAT JOB TODAY. THE
NEXT FLOOR SESSION IS SCHEDULED
FOR TOMORROW. TUESDAY MARCH 19TH
AT THREE. 30 P MA REMINDER THAT
WE'RE GONNA GAVEL IN AT THREE 30
. THEN THE SENATE WILL WALK OVER
TOGETHER AS ONE TEAM OVER TO THE
ASSEMBLY FOR THE STATE OF
JUDICIARY. THANK YOU SO MUCH, MR
PRESIDENT. THE SENATE WILL BE IN
RECESS UNTIL 4 P.M, AT WHICH
TIME THE ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL
BE MADE. THAT WE ARE ADJOURNED.